And they heard the voice of the Lord God
walking in the garden in the cool of the
day,
and Adam and his wife hid themselves
from the presence of the Lord God
amongst the trees of the garden.
That's interesting.
So what's the implication?
Priority being woken up prior to
recognizing nakedness and vulnerability.
There is no reason for God,
for man and woman to hide from God now
where they're hurting from God while
they're naked,
they're vulnerable.
Okay,
so think about this.
Think about this.
It's like imagine that you have the
capacity to live truthfully and
courageously and forthrightly.
Just imagine that and then imagine why
you might not do that.
And then imagined.
Well,
how about fear and shame?
How?
How would that work?
Well,
let's say that the idea of living
forthright,
Lee and truthfully and courageously is
analogous,
given what we already know about these
stories to walking with God in the
garden or what stops people from doing
that?
What stops people from hiding?
Well,
it's their own rates and recognition of
their own inadequacy.
They look at themselves and they think,
how in the world is a creature such as?
I supposed to live properly in this
world with everything that's wrong with
me,
and so what do you hide from?
Well,
you,
you go home,
you sit on your bed for five minutes and
ask yourself,
what have you hidden from in your life?
Man,
you'll have books of knowledge reveal
themselves to you in your imagination,
right?
Say,
well,
why are you hiding?
Well,
it's no bloody wonder.
You're hiding.
It's no wonder that people hide.
That's the thing that's so terrifying
about this story.
We woke up and we thought,
oh my God,
look at this place like this is
seriously.
There's some serious trouble here and
we're in some serious trouble and we're
not what we could be,
and so we hide and that's what the story
says.
People woke up,
they became self conscious.
They recognize their own vulnerability
and that make the,
made them hide from manifesting their
divine destiny.
It's like,
yeah,
that's exactly right,
and the Lord go there.
I love this part of the story and it's
so funny and the Lord God called and we
could use a little humor at this point,
and the Lord God called Unto Adam and
said unto him where Art Thou?
And Adam said,
I heard a voice in the garden and I f I
was afraid because I was naked.
So in case there was any doubt about
that.
That's why.
And I hid myself and God said,
who told you that you were naked?
Did you eat of the tree whereof I
commanded you that you should not eat.
And this is where Adam shows himself in
all his post fall,
heroic glory.
And the man said,
the woman
who no gave us to be with me,
she gave me of the tree and I did eat.
So that set,
that set that it's so,
you know,
again,
there's a modern feminist interpretation
of the story of Adam and eve that makes
the claim that eve was portrayed as the
universal bad guy of humanity for
disobeying God and eating the Apple.
It's like,
fair enough.
You know,
it looks like she slipped up and then
she tempted her husband and you know,
that makes her even worse,
although he's was foolish enough to
immediately eat,
so it just means she was a little more
courageous than him then got there
first,
but it's Adam who comes across as really
one sad creature in this story as far as
I'm concerned,
what he manages in one sentence.
It's like,
first of all,
it wasn't him.
It was the woman and said,
can even blames God.
It wasn't just the woman,
it was,
it was that woman and you gave her to me
and she gave me of the tree and I did
eat.
It's like,
so hey,
Adam was all innocent except now he's
not only is he naked and disobedient and
cowardly and ashamed.
He's also sniffily backbiting.
Think he writes her out like the second
he gets the opportunity and then he
blames God.
It's like,
and that's exactly right.
That's exactly right,
man.
You go online and you read,
you read the commentary that men write
about women when they're resentful and
bitter about women.
You read it.
It's so interesting.
It's like,
it's not me,
it's those bitches.
Okay.
That's right.
It's not me,
it's them.
And not only that,
what a bloody world this is in which
they exist.
It's exactly the same thing.
It's exactly the same thing and it is
absolutely pathetic.
All right.
Thank you.